normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
this tweet here from Elon himself he
said as I said earlier this week
decolonization and from The River To The
Sea and similar euphemisms necessarily
imply genocide clear calls for extreme
violence are against our terms of
service and will result in suspension
this is also in response to swipe right
here's he's responding to himself yes
decolonization necessarily implies a
Jewish genocide thus is unacceptable to
any reasonable person and this is what
Colin Wright had said to which El MOS
responded decolonization is the woke
version of jihad and it should be viewed
and treated that way right responded to
Elon by saying exactly when Hamas
slaughtered Israeli civilians in the
name of jihad on October 7th the woke
said this is what decolonization looks
like when they when they tell us
decolonization looks like Jihad we
should believe them yes now here's the
question uh do we agree with a social
media platform Banning people calling
for decolonization or for that matter
even Jihad I think I think that it
should be looked at just just as just
like any other time when someone calls
for violence so if you if you have a a a
platform that says we don't allow calls
for violence then talking about
decolonization and stuff then that's
considered violence in my opinion if you
don't if you allow anything then fine
you know if if x if x allows other calls
for violence and then they specifically
say we don't like this yeah that's what
I feel like too they're CRI call calling
people to commit violence is a crime now
the question is decolonization sits at
that Nexus point between academic
rhetoric and instructing people to go
and commit acts of violence not illegal
so what they try doing is they say we're
not calling for violence we're saying
decolonized but we know what decolonized
means even if they called for violence
if it's not an imminent threat with a
day and a time it's not illegal the
question is it knowing that this is not
illegal should it be banned but there's
been there's
been ctive enforcement of calls for
violence and things that are and are not
violence there's been there one the left
does tend to swear up and down that
things are not calls for violence that
clearly are calls for violence they say
that the protests and the the riots they
say that those aren't violence there's
there is a an ambiguity that the left
continues to rely on when they're
talking about things that they would
call direct action or riots are the
cries of the unheard yeah that it it's
exactly but it's an I agree that's a
fair point that I think it is a fair
point but it it's
still it still obfuscates the violent
nature of it what what what Phil is
referring to is how the left will say
we're going to engage in a direct action
everyone wear all black and masks and
gloves and show up at this time at this
location and what does direct action
mean direct action literally means
breaking the law or committing acts of
violence I am not I'm not going to be
cute and I'm not going to defend the
left I have been at way too many leftist
protests when they talk about peacefully
protesting that's not what direct action
is direct action is a phrase they come
up with when they're referring to either
blocking streets blocking doors fighting
with cops or throwing things is is that
is that just antifa that that does the
direct direct action stuff the Blacklock
so in the early in in the uh uh early
OCC at occupy I don't want to say early
days because this goes way back but I I
do want to give a shout out to our good
friends who participated in the battle
in Seattle which was a protest against
the WTO by the way by the left for some
reason now they're on the other side of
this but uh in New York we call him
antifa we just call them the black block
and and we didn't call them anarchists
either sometimes the word Anarchist gets
thrown around because it's used to
convey the idea that everyone
understands like if someone says the
anarchists we know they're referring to
the people wearing all black however
considering that half the people I don't
claim them but considering half the
people we were friends with were literal
anarchists rejected that false
philosophy of authoritarianism we knew
that wasn't correct so we just called
them the black block leftists or Black
Block extremist or the black block now
everyone refers to it as antifa cuz the
game they played back then was there is
no black block mhm Black Block is a
tactic not a thing right Black Block is
when people wear hoodies and it's like
then why do the same people all the time
have logos and wear the same clothes now
it's same thing with antifa antifa is
just an idea it's not a group there's
cells there's chapters they engage in
violence this is exactly why I or this
is this is indicative of the
actual vulnerability that liberalism has
liberalism takes the opposing view or
the argument from from someone else
takes it at face value and treats every
argument as if it is a honest argument
and if you're dealing with progressives
or socialist people that essentially
disregard or reject the Enlighten
Enlightenment values they don't see a
reason to be honest because power is the
goal not honesty so if they are looking
to win and they want to they want to go
ahead and cover up violent actions or or
or you know direct your attention
elsewhere they have no problem lying see
here here's my my interest at this
Junction being that I'm not really on
the left or the right uh is that I just
want to see this deescalate and I do not
want to I don't want to ever endorse
censorship protocols uh particularly if
they are kind of vague platitudes like
from the river to the sea or
decolonization like that is that is just
clearly not explicit enough of a threat
for it to to be illegal certainly not
illegal read France fanon's wretched of
the world and it's clear but Phil it's
notal leg legality but legality is not
the standard that's something I brought
up twit but he has brought that up he
said it's it's legal or lawful but not
awful remember when he was talking about
that or maybe it was his CEO that was
saying it he he Elon musk's point was
that you're not allowed to call for
extreme violence on their platform he
did not say it has to be illegal I said
that I said but in the past in the past
either y but awful yes exactly where he
said if it's lawful well I don't think
in any Court in the country you could
actually get a all lawful speech would
be permitted on the platform well I
thought I took the lawful uh awful but
lawful as being like that was where the
gray area so that was a direct reference
to what they would censor things that
were lawful but awful would be censored
oh it was that direction okay well then
I misunderstood so what what their what
their point was if it is lawful but
awful we will restrict it and hide it or
Worse who def exactly this is the
problem I I have no idea like once you
once you've gone down this path we I
mean we've already done this before
that's what's so frustrating just a
couple years ago we were doing this dud
Rumble we've been going through with
Rumble everyone's up in arms about
Rumble right now dude it's the same
rumble's going to get hit with this
Chris is going to make some stupid call
that ban some dumb thing and Chris I'm
I'm not I will put you on the spot
because you haven't called me back
lately but uh it's serious man you got
to decentralize that platform holding
this stuff in one Central Area is a
massive vulnerability and people can go
crazy the FBI can take your look
elon's whole claim elon's whole claim
for why he purchased Twitter or X was
that he understands allegedly how
important open dialogue and conversation
are it the entire when when it was the
left when it was hold on hold when it
was the left that was in control that
was that was absolutely Banning anybody
that was even like one degree to the
right I all all my libertarian friends
got banned too so I I took this
personally the the issue is that we
understand that we're we're prepared in
the battle in the the arena of ideas we
fear no man I want to I want to have
these conversations I don't want to see
these people banned that just
radicalizes them further but you're
talking about so it's one thing to say
that you're going to look that you're
you want your platform to be an open
exchange of ideas then the point is we
are not going to censor perspectives
we're not going to censor ideas right so
that's one thing but then it's one thing
to that's another that's different from
saying I want to kill all those people
right the the old Twitter the reason
that musk bought it it was because there
were entire ideas that were un that were
not allowed to be articulated it wasn't
that you couldn't say the nword or the k
word or whatever swear it wasn't about
vulgarity the vulgarity is what ends up
getting people in trouble it's not you
like you're never going to see martyr
made get booted from X because of the
way because the way that he talks about
stuff like he the whole Fear and
Loathing in in New Jerusalem that whole
thing if he didn't come at the stories
the way that he does and articulate them
the way that he does if he if he did it
Loosely and like he was posting and
stuff that that all that stuff would be
like anti-Semitism get out of here if he
was approaching it by being vulgar and
stuff but the the idea is completely
fine to share those ideas on X just so
long as you're not ship posting about it
because the ship posting is what ends up
offending people so in in on hold on on
X it's not censoring ideas and it used
to be before musk there were entire
ideas that you were not allowed to share
you couldn't say that some that a that a
man could not become a woman that would
offend someone and that would get Bo
that was ridiculous the Wuhan Institute
of furology I got suspended for that so
I know that was a big deal but the point
was it was about not preventing the
sharing of ideas is not about not saying
things that were offensive well but see
this is the issue is that this is still
an idea because what you what you're
talking about from from The River To The
Sea as you know there are lots of people
that don't feel that it is a call for
genocide I don't believe them I don't I
honestly I don't believe them when
people sayone of I I think you think
every single person that has said that
wants to see a genocide I think the vast
not a genocide but they think that if
they think that it's fine to say it
should be a democracy where everybody
there gets a say and the Jews would be
Jews and then it should be a one-state
solution and the Jews would end up
getting slaughtered I'm I'm sorry people
are get to mad at me for this but I
don't care if people started marching
marching around doing Roman salutes
while uh uh you know doing a SE high are
you going to be like not everybody
actually believes when Hamas puts out
their Charter and they include we we
read this this morning on the culture
War hamas's original charter included
the the the I I think Phil mentioned it
was one of the hadiths which quite
literally says the trees and the stones
will call out there's a Jew hiding
behind me so that the the Muslims can
come and hunt them and kill them down
kill them and their Charter actually
says that the there will not be Judgment
day until they've killed the Jews like
you can it's fair point not everybody
May mean that but that would be akin to
you know people going around doing a
Roman salute or I'll give you a better
one I've seen I've seen I saw a family
extended family member of mine do the
red salute at a March and I'm just like
it's so funny how many the fist the fist
where you show the fingers forward and
the reason why they do that so there's
there's the victory fist where you can
like hold your fist in the air and shake
it but the red salute is when you hold
your fingers forward and I'm not going
to make the fist on camera and it's
because it represents that each
individual finger is weak but together
is strong and you show your enemies so
when I see people doing that I'm like I
understand they don't literally want to
to Massacre and Slaughter a bunch of
people and they don't literally want a
communist takeover they might think some
things like this the problem is the
banality of evil those photos of
everybody doing the the SE High and the
Roman salute to Hitler didn't know what
they were they were throwing up for and
so when you have people marching through
the street chant chanting from The River
To The Sea by all means we can say maybe
that person doesn't really know but
nonetheless you have a large group of
people expressing the idea of Hamas yeah
and hamas's stated goal of wiping out
Jews I I don't disagree with with much
of that but here's here's the broader
issue I am a firm believer in open
dialogue and debate thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net